what do you think has happened because
the mayor of kremenchuk has said look
you know we are far removed from the
hostilities how on earth has this
happened and russia's explanation isn't
cutting it no not at all and over the
last 24 hours a great deal of forensic
material has gone on to social media
most of it's very good which is pretty
close i think to the truth there is a
plausible military target
close to the oil refinery in kremenchuk
which is the biggest refinery uh in
ukraine that's been hit twice in a month
anyway it's been out of action but
there's a target next to it which is a
an industrial area which does some
vehicle repairs but that is a thousand
yards away a full kilometer away from
the shopping center and the missile that
was used we know was an x-22 we're sure
about that um it should not have been
that inaccurate so there's almost no
other conclusion to draw unless it was a
crucial intelligence failure unless they
simply mistook the building and that
would be a massive massive intelligence
failure if it was then you have to
conclude that this x-22 was directed and
here it is going in exactly to the
shopping center it's an anti-ship
missile weighs five tons has a massive
warhead it's not normally supposed to be
used for this it's supposed to be used
against aircraft carriers and almost
certainly it was a deliberate attack on
a populated area absolutely horrifying
um the backdrop of course to this this
week is the nato summit that's got
underway and joe biden has been speaking
the white house in fact um the official
word from the white house um is saying
that in essence biden and the american
administration are losing confidence in
the fact that ukraine will ever regain
much of the territory it's losing in
this war and that president zielinski
may have to
redefine his version of what victory
will look like yes there's a sort of
pendulum swing in in world opinion about
whether ukrainians are winning or losing
or holding their own and so on the point
is that ukrainians are losing some
territory at the moment but not very
much i mean this this ferocious battles
going on it's very done yet it's going
over the river in leicestershire and
they are losing territory kilometer by
kilometer but they're also gaining
territory up north in kharkiv down in
the south in kirshon which are actually
bigger areas
but
the the fact is they're fighting for
their lives in the donbass and i think
the the name of the game the ukrainians
know this is a very dangerous period for
them because not not much of this
weaponry and ammunition has really
arrived yet it won't arrive for another
six weeks or two months or so and so
they're going through a very dangerous
period and i think their their thinking
i guess is that they must lose as little
territory as possible until the pendulum
moves in their favor which it should do
later in the summer with more people
more more people in uniform than the
russians have got and more weapons now
the question then is when things move in
their favor can they begin to liberate
more of this territory that's a
difficult question i think that's what
the americans are referring to
i think they can but it'll be later in
the year or into next year before they
do it and they've got to reorganize
themselves in order to conduct a real
strategic offensive but at the moment
their idea is lose as little territory
as you can in this really dangerous
period of the next six weeks or two
months when they're really short of
ammunition